should i call you as the rumors are
saying mr
attorney general of the united states is
there any truth
that joe biden has already spoken to you
and i know you are a truthful man
that you are about to become the
attorney general in the biden
administration
zero nada niente zilch
how many what else what else do you need
me to say
i think you could have run for president
m1 but you said you know what
most politicians you say this in the
book most politicians would take the
approach that the ultimate goal
is being present in the united states
your attitude as hard as it is for us to
imagine
is i wanted to run new york state and
you had
absolutely no desire to run for
president is that accurate
that is accurate let me give you a
little context though okay
sometimes uh you decide the best way to
help the team
is for you to play center field well i
really wanted to play first base i know
but you're
you're better at center field for the
team
that's one fact if you're if it's
actually about the team and it's
supposed to be about the team then play
the position where you can help the team
number two
i was in the middle of covid when all
this political conversation started
and i was desperate for a relationship
and credibility
with the people of my state and
the people across the country uh and i
know what they were thinking they were
thinking oh here he is another
politician these politicians always have
their own agenda they always want to
take the next step on the ladder
i needed to defuse that and the way to
defuse that
i said i am not interested in running
for president
vice president i'm not going to go to
washington i have
no agenda put your cynicism and your
skepticism aside
i have no agenda besides you
i just want to do this job so please
hear what i'm saying without all that
skepticism
and i said repeatedly this is this is
where i am and this is what i'm going to
do
and it allowed me i think it gave me
credibility in the cover discussion
uh and in truth we still have a long way
to go on covet and then we have to get
on to rebuilding this state and this
nation
and that's more than a full-time job